trouve claude blanchemaison on vient de
le rappeler ces commémorations pour ce
75e anniversaire de la victoire de la
russie sur l'allemagne nazie devait se
dérouler en gros c'est aussi un rendez
vous diplomatiques
quels échanges étaient très attendus
dans ce cadre je crois que le fait que
le président m'a emmanuel macron et
avait confirmé sa présence l'état est un
élément important
pas très étonnant d'ailleurs parce que
comme vous le savez le général de gaulle
avait fait en sorte qu'une unité
combattante de l'aviation participent à
cette guerre avec l'armée rouge il
s'agit du fameux de la fameuse
escadrille normandie niémen on peut
d'ailleurs penser que comme ça s'est
déjà fait dans le passé
un détachement de la base de
mont-de-marsan qui porte la tradition de
normandie niemen pourrait aussi défilé à
l'occasion est en effet ces militaires
ces aviateurs français se sont battus
dans le ciel russes à l'époque et on a
battu plusieurs avions de l'allemagne
nazie par conséquent il ya une tradition
dans sept ans ce sur ce sujet une idée
française s'est battu avec les troupes
soviétiques
je note que dans son discours dans son
nom dans sa courte intervention le
président russe a salué l'exploit de
tous deux des soviétiques et des toutes
les nationalités qui composent l union
soviétique
une ces nationalités qui sont
naturellement les kazakhes
les ukrainiens et biélorusses les
ouzbeks et beaucoup d'autres qui depuis
ils sont devenus indépendants donc cette
notation est aussi assez importante et
ces pays
aujourd'hui devenus indépendants marque
évidemment l'anniversaire du neuf mais
également françois chavance et du côté
des occidentaux en retient encore
aujourd'hui que les grands vainqueurs de
la seconde guerre mondiale sont les
américains entend beaucoup moins parler
du rôle joué par là
aussi dans la victoire contre
l'allemagne nazie comment est-ce qu'on
vous l'expliquer je pense que ces
preuves de l'histoire on voit toujours
un petit peu ce qui se passe à sa porte
et pas un peu plus loin un tènement ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
n'oublions pas quand même que suite à
cette deuxième guerre mondiale le monde
s'est divisée en deux en europe
nous avions quand même un bloc de l'est
et un bloc de l'ouest et que je crois
que cet effacement plus ou moins
volontaire mais pas forcément de lin de
l'implication de l'union soviétique à
l'époque a été plus ou moins
idéologiquement me semble-t-il sans
doute est ignorée ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne la prend pas dans les livres
d'histoire les enfants les collégiens
apprennent cette histoire donc il n'ya
pas une volonté délibérée d'effacer le
rôle de l'ex union soviétique mais
néanmoins je pense que dans le collectif
c'est quand même un petit peu le
résultat de cette guerre froide qui a
fait qu'on n'a plus mis en valeur
l'occident d'un côté que l'ex union
soviétique et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
rétablit une certaine vérité de
l'histoire
chacun a pris sa part à cette guerre
tout le monde ya contribué à sa manière
avec le seul résultat obtenir c'était la
destruction de l'état nazi et je crois
que c'est ce qui a été obtenu et que je
dirais qu'avec le temps on revient qu'un
juste équilibre dans la compréhension de
cette histoire compliquée un clown
blanche raison qu'elle était quels chefs
militaires et et staline a selon vous à
vos yeux
bah je crois qu'en tout cas le peuple
russe aujourd'hui lui reconnaît d'avoir
été capable de tenir tenir notamment
pendant le siège de stalingrad qui a été
un siège extrêmement meurtrier et
également pendant le siège de leningrad
pendant le siège bien entendu de moscou
après tout ça n'était pas évident de
tenir aussi longtemps avec des pertes
aussi importante du côté soviétique
et je rappelle que à l'époque où moscou
a été assiégé le gouvernement soviétique
avait prévu avait déjà installé
d'ailleurs à un repli dans la ville de
kunming chef sur la volga qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui la ville de samarra est un
petit chef on avait installé d'ailleurs
un pc de commandement pour staline à 50
mètres sous terre que l'on visite encore
aujourd'hui certaines ambassades s'était
déjà replié aquabeat chef parce que on
n'était pas sûr que moscou puisse tenir
le siège et c'est la volonté de staline
qui a fait que les troupes ont pu ont pu
tenir
je crois que c'est cela que aujourd'hui
les russes reconnaissent installés alors
comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure
bien entendu sur le plan militaire il
faut faire le partage entre les chefs
militaires qui avaient leur propre
stratégie et leur tactique à mettre en
oeuvre et puis les instructions que
pouvait leur donner un staline mais en
tout cas les instructions de staline
était toujours de tenir et vous françois
jeu lancé vous qui est un général de
brigade
comment est ce que vous voyez installer
nos rangs tant que chef militaire va
effectivement je rejoins ce qui vient
d'être dit chefs militaires sûrement pas
chef de guerre sûrement je crois quand
même que les pertes en hommes ont été
terribles et aussi parce que l'humain
n'a pas été considéré comme un humain y
compris par staline comme il fallait
tenir comme ça vient d'être appelé il
n'y a pas eu beaucoup de scrupules à
faire tuer des milliers d'hommes dans
des assauts parfois dignes de la
première guerre mondiale
mais il fallait tenir donc chef de
guerre
oui parce que un homme politique doit
être capable de tenir maintenant
reconnaissons quand même que le système
soviétique que permettait difficilement
à l'opposition quelle qu'elle soit y
compris de députés par exemple de
s'opposer à la guerre et de demander
fait donc je crois que le régime
totalitaire de staline qui ne faut pas
quand même négligé a permis que l'armée
tienne et que le peuple tienne parce que
ils font un chef fort dans une crise
bon maintenant les moyens qui ont été
utilisés c'est à dire des pertes
humaines énorme ont apporté la victoire
alors après l'histoire jugera
on constate aujourd'hui que pour le
peuple russes staline a quand même été
un homme d'importance dans son histoire
et qui a permis finalement aujourd'hui à
la russie d'exister et je crois que
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir
malgré tous les aléas d'une guerre dont
on n'est jamais mettre un condom dans
cette maison rappelez-nous un peu l'état
des forces au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer cette domination
américaine à quoi est-ce qu'elle est
dieu nous faisons tout ce que nous nous
parlions ce matin c'est évidemment la
fin de la guerre en or c'est à dire la
chute du nazisme mais ça n'est pas tout
à fait la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
comme vous savez les opérations
militaires ont continué pendant un
certain temps ou dans le pacifique en
asie pour venir à bout du régime
militariste japonais et à ce titre
d'ailleurs
l'union soviétique avait des
conversations avec les japonais qui
essayait de maintenir l'union soviétique
en dehors de ce conflit dans le
pacifique
et puis finalement les soviétiques mais
assez tardivement sont adhérents sont
entrés en guerre contre le japon en
envahissant le monde sous peu la partie
nord de la corée et toute une partie de
cette région les îles kouriles également
le sud de sakhaline et
effectivement on était le 2 septembre à
la signature la cérémonie de signature
de la reddition du japon
pour revenir à votre question et à la
situation des forces au lendemain de la
signature de la reddition sans
conditions de l'allemagne nazie donc le
9 mai 1945
évidemment en europe et bien il y avait
eu la conférence de yalta auparavant et
à yalta en effet les grands de ce monde
c'était un peu partagé les zones
d'affluence en europe et staline et le
président américain winston churchill
avait tracé des lignes sur une carte de
l'europe pour dessiner le partage des
zones d'affluence
le général de gaulle a toujours contesté
cette façon de faire puisque la france
il n'était pas à yalta et en effet il là
il l'a fait savoir
alors effectivement comme vous le savez
le général de gaulle avait d'ailleurs
effectué un voyage tout affairé pic en
union soviétique dès 1944 pour signer un
accord un accord avec staline ya eu
d'ailleurs beaucoup de mal à le signer
mais finalement cet accord a été signé
et il a marqué en effet que la france
libre est l interlocuteur valable
alors le rapport des forces il est que
dans les pays de la partie occidentale
de l'europe
c'est évidemment les états unis
d'amérique qui domine et qui d'ailleurs
ont leurs troupes eu un peu partout et
puis dans la partie orientale de cette
europe
et bien c'est l'union soviétique c'est
la conséquence de yalta et de les guider
ou des opérations militaires on parle
françois chavance et de l'héroïsme des
soldats soviétiques hitler entendait on
rappelle anéantir l'urss notamment pour
y piller les matières premières et les
populations l'on a très durement payé à
tout à fait et où on peut être que
comment dire surpris mais
par le courage du soldat russe
soviétique pas si c'est vrai qu'il n'y
avait pas que des russes
la volonté de se battre jusqu'au bout
mais je répète quand je dis tout à
l'heure il y avait quand même un système
autoritaire derrière qui permettait
difficilement aux soldats russes de se
rebeller ou de ne pas faire la guerre
bon il faut quand même pas l'oublier
maintenant il est indéniable que tout ce
qu'on peut lire sur cette guerre
patriotique a montré que le soldat
soviétique était patriotes ils défendent
est sa terre il défend des sa famille il
ne défendrait pas forcément le régime
mais c'était vraiment une guerre
d'agression qui subissaient et que je
crois que ce cette réflexion sur
l'engagement du soldat qui n'était pas
que professionnel mérite d'être souligné
nous avons des gens qui se sont battus
jusqu'à la mort sans état d'âme et pour
amener cette victoire et ce qui explique
les pertes phénoménales qui a subi l'une
aux soviétiques et je crois que cette
réflexion de cette guerre du passé doit
se se réfléchir aujourd'hui vous avez
évoqué par votre reportage tout à
l'heure cette historienne qui évoque les
ouvrages en france sur historique sur
l'histoire et c'est vrai en france la
notion de guerre aujourd'hui est quand
même une notion qui est éloigné parler
de la guerre patriotique de l'union
soviétique tous ces morts toute cette
guerre atroce
ce n'est pas dans l'air du temps et ce
qui explique pourquoi les livres
d'histoire finalement édulcore en partie
ce l'implication de l'union soviétique
n'est pas uniquement tous nos livres
d'histoire refuse la guerre or la guerre
c'est l'engagement de l'individu d'une
collectivité fasse une menace grave et
je crois que ce que cette commémoration
cette 75ème anniversaire montre bien cet
engagement total qu'un peuple peut avoir
face à une menace sur sa survie